hello and welcome to this video playing
and I'm queen fish wow it's a really low
rating for freedom master and they're
ready to get paired against even more
caution required yeah don't blunder
stuff renamed nope I can prevent Bishop
g5 in this kind of position yeah what
has pushed in the center it's not so
clear how good this is because um I will
get some pressure with Bishop g4 coming
or not I came so what you do here maybe
a rupee eight maybe I will take on d4
Bishop f5 and 94 this kind of piece
piece play appears pressure against the
center looks okay yeah what is taking
quite a bit of time him oh that's not
very exciting taking with the rook it's
a little bit dicey but it's also more
interesting than the other continuation
so let's see efore probably is going to
be played and then route h5 looks
extremely funky yeah but this is
interesting isn't it
edgy force is working I can put the rook
on edge force it would be extremely
cheeky let's drive
it's very cheeky if it doesn't work okay
then I'm conceding lots of points
against the 1900 player I know it's the
feed master but I don't really give much
both these titles in blitz it's about
the rating if you have a 1900 rating
it's 1900 doesn't really matter what
title you have okay a 95 I have to go
for that but it's quite interesting this
type of change sacrifice well here the
rook is hanging right the rook on a1 is
hanging hmm okay or you see basically
claiming that I don't have a square
anyway for that rook maybe
we should be three okay well I don't
have square cm for the father look
okay let's actually try to get a square
with age five and if he takes Bishop
takes Asus IRA
uh-huh what no no draw this is a pretty
decent compensation at least you okay
one queen G for a queen if for f3 just
about her walls
okay returns returns stuff immediately
if I take here their screen to be seven
very strong okay so I have to play I
don't want you but I probably have to
play c6 ruku t1 Bishop g4 should be okay
yeah the compensation on the light
squares is pretty decent here maybe just
goes Ruby one yeah I think I'll do this
to have locally six cover cover d6 if
necessary you know I want to have d5 so
this is not a passive more strictly
strictly speaking okay so where to put
it
maybe here
rookie four would be cool but doesn't
work there was a chick okay maybe I mean
that was unnecessary and rook bishop
before would have been would have been
good I guess I can still give this until
two there so you see it's going to to d8
here and probably here so I was thinking
that Queen age five and so on should be
super dangerous
but maybe I'm I'm just just wrong Jackie
I mean here threatens bishop bone bishop
age three
those light squares looking more than
shade white resins yeah I think there is
no defense actually yeah I was a pretty
pretty cheeky way to play with this with
this book maneuver
my dad said this actually worked but
okay man told me it didn't
yeah yeah I probably this is just a bit
to be too cheeky and 95 okay now I'm
sacrificing him the engine gives a clear
refutation with the move that I didn't
consider Knight f4 wow wow that looks
bad if it was half of the brook I have
to do this oh my god that's pretty awful
okay okay I think here I'm probably kind
of okay I think this is this is
compensation for the pond covering and
here I have compensation but I think the
real issue comes a little bit later I
think probably this isn't working
King edge - also not quite clear what
this move is doing it mostly gives me
queen h5 check the engine wants to play
this and after Bishop before assesses
this pollution as equal okay and the
computer is probably a very good adviser
here even though from a practical point
of view White's position is pretty awful
too plain so I definitely prefer black e
and a practical game jack yeah this is
justice justice checkmate
you know Bishop e3 essa is a deadly
threat if he takes at him I'm mating
next okay well thanks for watching